und wir wollen jetzt auch noch mal über
die gescheiterten friedensverhandlungen
in antalya sprechen und dazu
zugeschaltet ist der ehemalige deutsche
außenminister sigmar gabriel schirm und
herr gabriel schön dass sie die zeit
haben
grüßen sie sind ja nun auch einige male
schon mit dem russischen außenminister
lavrov zusammen gekommen sie kennen ihn
gut was ist er für ein typ
na ja das ist schon jemand der ziemlich
robust verhandeln kann aber ich glaube
nicht dass sergej lawrow die
entscheidungen trifft ich glaube dass er
nur einen begrenzten
verhandlungsspielraum hat
wir wollen wir kurz reinhören in einige
seiner aussagen der heute getroffen hat
dass ihre frage ob wir in europa andere
länder angreifen kann ich nur sagen weil
das haben wir nicht wollen dass die
ukraine greifen wie nichts an wir haben
immer wieder immer wieder erklären dass
eine situation entsteht wo unmittelbare
sicherheitsbedrohungen für die russische
föderation entstehen
immer wieder viele jahre immer wieder
vorschläge unterbreitet uns wurde nie
gehör geschenkt und herr präsident putin
hat das immer wieder
wie bewerten sie solche aussagen von la
france
das ist ja zynisch wenn sie sich die
bilder aus der ukraine anschauen oder
wenn sie gestern mit dem zug von berlin
richtung westen gefahren er war voller
flüchtlinge und zwar immer frauen mit
ihren kindern wenn sie das sehen dann
können sie solche bemerkungen der neues
zynisch empfinden denn natürlich ist das
ein angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine und
zwar der erste große krieg in europa
seit dem ersten september 1939 ein
schwerer bruch der minimalstandards des
internationalen rechts und ist ganz egal
was da auf der pressekonferenz gesagt
wird die tatsachen sprechen für sich
was meinen sie genau damit die tatsachen
sprechen für sich wenn jemand panzer
über die gründe über die grenze eines
benachbarten landes geschickt und städte
einkreist und beschießt wie soll man das
anders bezeichnen als krieg
wie kann man jetzt aus dieser
kriegssituation aus dieser pattsituation
in der man ja offensichtlich bei den
verhandlungen jetzt ist ihrer meinung
nach wieder rauskommen wir haben ja
schon jede menge sanktionen verhängt die
fangen jetzt auch langsam an zu wirken
welche diplomatischen möglichkeiten gibt
es ihrer meinung noch
ich glaube nicht dass wir eine schnelles
ergebnis erreichen werden denn
offensichtlich hat sich der russische
präsident das ziel gesetzt die ukraine
tatsächlich einzel nehmen das schafft er
bei weitem nicht so schnell wieder das
gedacht hat um eine große angst ist dass
wir eher schlimmere bilder sehen werden
im übrigen glaube ich auch nicht dass
russland ein land mit 41 millionen
einwohnerinnen und einwohnern noch so
viele soldaten beherrschen kann im
zweifel gibt dass ein guerillakrieg und
attentate wie wir das mal in irland mit
der ira hatten ich glaube russland hat
schon verloren das hat wirtschaftlich
verloren das heißt politisch verloren
das ist der paria der weltpolitik ist
ganz egal was sie militärisch machen aus
der lage kommen sie nicht raus und meine
hoffnung ist dass auch länder wie china
den druck auf russland erhöhen wir
wenigstens einen waffenstillstand
herbeizuführen sieht momentan aber
zumindest nicht danach aus denn auch
jena hat ja eigene wirtschaftliche
interessen
ja also erstens fand ich es
bemerkenswert dass die chinesische
staatspräsident anders als sein
außenminister was auch das ganze in der
ukraine als krieg erklärt hat das war
eine wesentlich klare haltung und im
übrigen glaube ich dass in china sichert
zwei
unterschiedliche gruppen existieren da
wird es die geben die sich darüber
freuen dass die usa sich wieder um
russland und europa kümmern müssen dann
nicht so sehr in china und die natürlich
auch sehen dass russland ihm wie eine
reife frucht in den schoß fällt denn man
hat überhaupt keinen anderen partner
mehr als china derzeit aber es gibt eben
auch die andere seite die wissen dass
schwere wirtschaftliche störung der
weltwirtschaft und die werden wir
erleben dass das am ende auch china
trifft und das einzige was die
chinesische führung wirklich braucht ist
dass sich der wohlstand ihrer
bevölkerung jedes jahr vermehrt und mit
einer gestörten weltwirtschaft und
ölpreisen von fast irgendwann 200 dollar
pro barrel öl wird das auch in china
nicht gelegen und ich glaube dass diese
haltung die chinesen möglicherweise dann
doch dazu bringt auf russland einfluss
zu nehmen aber ich gebe zu das alles
sind keine schnellen ergebnisse und
solange der krieg weitergeht werden die
menschen dort leiden und genau das ist
der punkt wie kann man diesen krieg
tatsächlich jetzt zumindest vorläufig
erst mal beenden wie kann man zumindest
mal dazu kommen eine waffenruhe
herzustellen selbst das ist ja in
antalya nicht gelungen ich sehe keine
möglichkeit solange russland das nicht
will wenn die ukraine können und der
ukrainische präsident können ja nicht
den russischen forderungen nachkommen
und mal eben so ein teil ihres landes
aufgeben die ost ukraine
also so lange das quasi die die die die
niederwerfung der ukraine die
voraussetzung dafür ist dass da was ich
dann herrscht wird es nicht gelingen so
bitter das ist schauen wir noch mal auf
die rolle deutschlands haben sie das
gefühl dass wir uns in den letzten
jahren einfach zu sehr abhängig gemacht
haben von russischem gas von russischem
öl und dass wir deswegen auch nicht
wirklich in der lage sind so zu ergehen
wie wir das gerne wollten
na ja wir haben alle in europa vor 25
jahren eine entscheidung getroffen die
wir heute bereuen wir haben mich gesagt
der staat soll raus aus der
verantwortung für die
versorgungssicherheit das nannte man
liberalisierung der energiemärkte ein
tolles wort ist aber nichts anderes als
der staat hat nicht mehr die
verantwortung sondern wir überlassen das
den märkten und was machen die sie
suchen sich
anbieter das war russisches pipeline
gast das ist der grund der jetzige
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck hat zu
recht gesagt dass man das wieder ändern
muss aber wir haben lange gedacht dass
gebe so was wie eine friedensdividende
auch in der energiepolitik und russland
hat uns leider eines besseren belehrt
nicht nur deutschland sondern
bulgarien ist ein land das zu 100
prozent am russischen gasmarkt italien
abhängig wir sind nicht die einzigen
aber das macht es ja nicht besser das
macht es nicht besser und wir haben
zusätzlich auch noch beschlossen unsere
akw vom netz zu nehmen
vorzeitig war das vielleicht ein fehler
das glaube ich nicht
dann die kernenergie hat ja es gibt ja
gründe warum wir das gemacht haben ich
gehöre zu denen die ihren eigenen
wahlkreis mal ein endlager eingerichtet
haben ich habe mal gesagt ich rede nur
mit denen über die fortsetzung der
atomenergie die bereit sind bei sich zu
hause auch so was zu machen solange wir
die endlagerfrage nicht klären sondern
immer weiter neuen atommüll produzieren
von dem werde ich wissen wohin damit
halte ich das nicht für eine
verantwortbare energie wir brauchen das
übrigens auch nicht wir müssen eine
beschleunigung der erneuerbaren
hinkriegen dazu muss man in deutschland
schneller werden das können wir in der
politik wenn wir die planungszeiträume
verkürzen wenn wir nicht überall klage
wege beschreiten ist keineswegs so dass
wie hilflos sind
nun muss man aber sagen was unsere
bundeswehr angeht ja da sind wir zwar
nicht hilflos das möchte ich so nicht
sagen aber zumindest nicht besonders gut
aufgestellt nun haben sie in ihrer
amtszeit damals auch gesagt als es hieß
ja dass zwei prozent zählen die nato das
wir erreichen muss aufstocken gebt das
geld sollte man lieber in
entwicklungshilfe stecken bereuen sie
das heute
glaube nicht dass man die beiden dinge
gegeneinander ausspielen kann wir
brauchen beides wir brauchen natürlich
ein militär das seinen aufgaben gerecht
wird da ist seit 2005 die cdu csu
verantwortlich für die ist
verteidigungsministerium gewesen sind
große fehler gemacht worden die man
korrigieren muss übrigens nicht nur mit
geld es gibt auch eine technokratische
struktur in der bundeswehr dass das geld
das man rein gibt am ende nicht zu mehr
sicherheit führt das spricht aber nicht
dafür es in der entwicklungshilfe
weniger zu machen denn natürlich haben
wir auch andere bedrohungen als als
russland wenn ich sehe wie krieg und
bürgerkrieg und armut und klimawandel
dazu führt dass immer mehr menschen
heimat verlassen müssen dann wissen wir
was wir mehr zu tun haben ich glaube wir
sind in einer zeit wo wir eher mit mehr
unsicherheit werden leben müssten und
wir werden uns nicht davor drücken
können beides zu tun einerseits für die
eigene sicherheit zu sorgen andererseits
mitzuhelfen dass das leben in anderen
teilen der welt erträglich wird herr
gabriel erlauben sie mir zum abschluss
noch eine kurze frage zu gerd schröder
der befindet sich gerade in moskau
wussten sie davon von dieser reise und
was sagen sie dazu
natürlich legt ich meine ich kann nur
das gleiche sagen was der ukrainische
botschafter vor einigen tagen ich glaube
bei der bild gesagt hat dass er hat ja
denn jetzt schöner sogar aufgefordert zu
putin zu fahren das tut er jetzt ob das
erfolg hat oder nicht wird man sehen
aber im zweifel hat der ukrainische
botschafter recht wenn er sagt man muss
alles versuchen selbst das trauen sie
eben denn zu dass er tatsächlich als
friedensvermittler erfolgreich sein kann
wenn es erst mal vernünftig dass er das
versucht aber ich meine die sprache die
russland derzeit spricht
deutet nicht darauf hin dass hier
persönliche beziehungen zu einer
veränderung der russischen politik führt
aber das er es versuchte in ordnung
hatten sie sich vielleicht gewünscht
dass er die bundesregierung vorher in
kenntnis setzt oder zumindest auch die
spd spitze ich weiß nicht mal ob er das
gemacht hat keine ahnung hat er nicht
also ich weiß noch gar nix deswegen kann
ich dazu auch nicht sagen
herr gabriel ich danke ihnen sehr ich
danke ihnen sehr dass sie sich die zeit
für uns genommen haben